let's talk about the entrepreneur's
mindset i'm going to get through as many
of these as i can and i usually do this
for about 30 40 minutes and then i
switch over to taking questions but if
you like what you're about to get here
you're going to love what's in the
course so let's start with mindset um
i think it's incredibly important to
talk about
the
um
i guess just like the end point the goal
uh the first epoch in the business you
know if i can say
and most people never think about this
they just think i'll start a business
it'll make some money i'll generate some
income everything will be great
and life will be
uh you know 2.0 version sort of thing um
but a lot of guys think way too small
and by that it's reflected in the data
most businesses which amount to about 97
when i say most never pass a 1 million
dollar mark in annual sales
i'm gonna say that again most businesses
never get past a million dollars a month
in annual sales so when you hear of
things like big corporations like
microsoft apple tesla
there are anomalies okay
they are definitely the exception for
people to start businesses the vast
majority of people that get into
business are business for self and they
generally create a job
a company that can employ them so they
have a job
so
you don't have the big advantages you
don't have the big upside so
the first point that i'm making here
about mindset is you need to generally
think bigger most people don't think big
enough when it comes to business you
want to try to get into a market that
has
uh scalability that has uh the
opportunity for you to make considerably
more than a million dollars a year in
sales because the amount of work that
you're going to do
probably to run a
i mean what what the go-to is for most
people is a brick and mortar shop with a
sign on the front with a neon open sign
and uh they fulfill some service right
they make a few hundred thousand dollars
a year they have to pay for rent they
have to pay for uh
like all their overhead utilities and of
course salaries
and they end up basically paying
themselves 100 grand a year to become an
employee of a company that's doing a few
hundred thousand
and it may make a little bit of profit
but you don't have anything that's
sellable
you don't have you generally don't have
a book of business that you can sell to
another business because that's
attractive right i mean
one of the things that
um second time round and third time
around entrepreneurs usually generally
by the second time round if they have to
shut something down they go bankrupt or
they sell it is they realize you want to
book a business you want something that
has some value so that when a buyer
comes along they say oh look you have
you know 3 672 customers and they're
paying an average of 357 dollars and 12
cents a month
that looks like x valuation right and
then you walk away with a nice big fat
paycheck
so again
thinking bigger is going to make a
significant difference
in the outcome and the experience that
you have it's roughly the same amount of
work whether you're gonna build a five
million dollar a year business
or five hundred thousand dollar a year
business
it's just how you're thinking about the
scalability and the opportunity later on
down the road so
make sure the market's big enough is
basically what i'm saying with that
first one hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you